speaking fair and balanced let's take an
objective even-handed look at some
comments that were made on Friday by oh
aaron rodgers his first discussion with
reporters since the packers moved up in
round one to select jordan love in the
2020 draft now this was wisconsin media
not national media and all that that
implies when it comes to what kind of
fast balls or softballs or or curveballs
may be thrown at aaron rodgers all due
respect let's play some of what rodgers
had to say chris and then we can react
to it here is rodgers fairly early in
the conference call regarding his
reaction to the team's decision to make
jordan love its first-round pick general
reaction at first was was surprised and
i like many people you know obviously
not gonna say that I was you know
thrilled by by the picniced early but I
understand the organization is thanking
not only about the present but about the
future and I respect that you know I
understand understand the their focus
and their mindset and obviously they
thought that he was such a great talent
that they needed to go up and get them
so um you know I was like I said
generally surprised but you know it's
it's what it's what those guys are paid
to do to put together a roster for now
and for the future as well a balance of
candor and diplomacy there from Aaron
Rodgers I mean he never comes out and
says hey they could have used that pick
and it wasn't just the first-round pick
it was the fourth round pick they used
to jump up for spots they could have
used those selections on making the team
better now helping us win a Super Bowl
now he didn't say that but is he really
just say that anybody who gets it knows
that that's the trade off but yeah he
said he wasn't thrilled by it but he
respects that that's what those guys
have to do there was nothing in there
that was inflammatory and there was
nothing in there that was surprising he
said pretty much what I would have
guessed he was going to say if I had to
script it ahead of time yeah I mean I'm
with you as well you know the one thing
I like about Aaron Rodgers is he always
confronts the situation and takes it
head-on and yeah you know he's usually
very honest I mean whether that's a
popular thing he says or an unpopular
thing
you know he's not afraid to say it
that's where the thing I've really
respect about him yeah of course he
wasn't happy he let you let everybody
know with those comments you know but I
also think that yeah he's got a good
good good view of the big picture of
what the Green Bay Packers are trying to
do as an organization now listen do I
think that the Packers are thinking a
little too far into the future right now
with Jordan love and all that and then
back the quarterback splice old you know
deep into the 30s and early 40s yes I do
that's why I don't agree with the pic
but I think Rodgers I think is gonna
play this the right way he realizes
where he is that at this point of his
career I also think he realizes hey I
want to keep the organization happy and
you know everything going on the
up-and-up cuz we got a good football
team and he'd like to win another Super
Bowl for Green Bay and for himself and
his legacy and everything that way too
so he doesn't want to ruin that right
now when he deems like hey I got a team
in to the Super Bowl window let me knock
crap on my organization and make things
dysfunction of the where I can't get
back to the Super Bowl he realizes the
big picture this is an extremely
intelligent guy and I thought he really
handled himself well with this interview
he also addressed his relationship with
Jordan love a guy he spoken to multiple
times here's some Aaron Rodgers
regarding his new colleague you know
I've learned a lot over the over those
years working with Brett things that I
can bring to the relationship with
Jordan and just understand the mindset
you know I was I went through it as a
young 21 22 23 year old playing with my
idol as a teammate and I'll definitely
definitely take those lessons with me
and like I said before I've always had
great relationships in my backups and
always loved helping those guys out and
in any way you know the more questions
they have the more answers I have and
and I really truly embraced those
relationships and it'll be the same with
Jordan II he didn't get asked to be
drafted by the time there's there's
nothing you know he's not to blame at
all you know he's just coming in excited
about his opportunity we had a great
conversation the day after the draft and
and I'm excited to work with him
uh you know he also said there's a
shared background between love and Aaron
Rodgers and I like the fact that Rodgers
is looking for similarities not
dissimilarities and the shared
background is came out of school
lightly recruited had to go prove
themselves and you know maybe this is
Aaron Rodgers opportunity to look at the
situation and say and this is something
that that we didn't play for you but
Rodgers did say I
Jordan Love didn't ask to be drafted by
the Packers he's not too bright in here
right and and I I I hope that this is a
sign that Aaron Rodgers is gonna break
the chain right that he's not going to
treat Jordan love the way that Brett
Favre treated Aaron Rodgers and you know
the whole concept of hazing the whole
concept of treating the new guy like
crap well why do you do that well
because I got treated like crap when I
was the new guy yeah it all flows
downhill wouldn't it be great if Aaron
Rodgers rises above that and doesn't
treat Aaron retreat Jordan love the way
he got treated by Brett Favre because he
was treated mercilessly by Brett Favre
right Favre didn't want him there Favre
was jealous of him Favre resented him
Favre treated him like crap and it took
15 years for them to to find a
friendship out of all that but maybe
this is a sign that Aaron Rodgers isn't
gonna do - Jordan love what Brett Favre
did Aaron Rodgers I think so you know
again I think Rodgers he understands the
big picture of football his legacy you
know and what has happened to him in his
personal life and I think Rodgers you
know you and I have both we both know
that yeah I don't think Brett Favre is
like overwhelmingly nice to Aaron
Rodgers early on in his career
I think if Brett Favre was like hey
screw you young kid I still got some
good football here and I don't give a
damn what you do and I'm not sitting
here trying to teach you or make you any
better I'm sure that bothered Aaron
Rodgers to where he won't be the same
guy and you know to the fact of Aaron
Rodgers talked about it I think it hurt
his soul a little bit that Brett Favre
taught him like that I mean hey nobody
is played like more like Brett Favre
than Aaron Rodgers says Brett Favre's
left the game you mean you just heard
Aaron Rodgers
that was his idol Brett Farve I think
Jordan loved one of his idols is Aaron
Rodgers hey one of the things I saw from
Jordan love and one of the first things
I wrote down was man has a lot of
Rodgers mannerisms and throwing styles
and things like that I'm sure that's
what Green Bay saw and liked about it
you know so Rodgers I think is gonna
have a soft spot in his heart for how he
was treated with his idol and he's gonna
wanna be a better Idol for this new
young kid and the big point is what he
said don't blame George and love this is
not his fault
Jordan Love just worked hard and had a
good career at Utah State and impress
people you know and the the post college
career workouts and bowl games and
things like that so you can't blame him
he didn't call Green Bay and said hey
please draft me I want to stir the pot
in Green Bay and I know a Aaron Rodgers
no not at all
I think Rodgers will take the right
approach with love Jordan Love has also
addressed the situation separately we
don't have the sound of that but here's
what he said as to his selection in
round one and justifying the faith and
then no matter where I would have landed
that was the goal for me you got to go
out there prove yourself and make a name
for yourself it's a job you got to be
able to keep that for me just trying to
learn the offense and prove myself and
look he is in the tough spot and and
these guys are wired to never say
anything that that would suggest they're
not happy with how things played out but
surely Jordan love would have preferred
being taken by a team that didn't have
one of the all-time great quarterbacks
looming on the roster in front of him
and have an opportunity to get to the
starting job without about without a
bunch of controversy without a huge set
of expectations when he becomes the
starter if he ever becomes the starter
and when that happens remains to be seen
because Aaron Rodgers has made it clear
that he is determined to continue to be
the Packers starter beyond his current
contract he has said time and again time
and again he wants to play into his 40s
he wants a finish his career with the
Packers that is clear there's no
misunderstanding about that Chris and
that's an important point because here
comes what I think was the key question
and answer from this conference call on
Friday on Rodgers future with the
package we got the question and the
answer we're gonna play it for you and
then we'll react on the other side I
know we've all heard you say you wanted
to finish your career as a packer even
beyond your current contract do you
think this pick affects that in any way
and is that fill your plan to do that
well I think what it does is just
reinforced kind of the the adage that
you can only control what you can
control and it's always been you know a
mantra for myself and I think any you
know any great athlete you know there's
things are just out of our control that
obviously is this some is very important
to me but you know is definitely telling
at this point that that is truly
something that's out of my control what
I can control is how I play and making
that decision at some point a very hard
one you know if I were to retire on the
organization's timetable then it's an
easy decision but if there comes a time
where I still feel like I can play at a
high level and and my body feels great
you know then there's you know other
guys who have gone on and played
elsewhere that's the kicker that's the
key and Chris I wrote an item on Friday
during the conference called once I
heard that once I took down the key
language I posted it I tweeted it and
Packers fans lost their mind germ is
characterizing what he said he never
said that he never said he it was clear
that he's going to play somewhere else
if the Packers decide to move on before
he's ready to retire football well yes
he did you just heard it it's as clear
as it can be if there comes a time where
I feel like I can play at a high level
and my body feels great there are other
guys that have gone on and played
elsewhere and that is right in the smack
dab middle of a context of what happens
if the Packers want to move on before he
is ready to move on from the game and
it's obvious we already knew that but he
said it there's a starkness that comes
into it there's a quality it makes it
real that makes it Roy and Packers fans
Chris they want to plug their fingers in
their ears and say a lot a lot a lot not
listening they don't want to face
reality they don't want to worry about
this this thing that's just kind of
hovering over the franchise now sorry
folks it's there we're not doing our
jobs we don't point it out feel free to
ignore
or it but it's there well don't get mad
at Mike Florio is what I want to tell
all those people and you know again it's
just another aaron rodgers he just he's
a very real guy there's no BS enough and
he understands the situation and he sees
it as a whole so you know don't get
frustrated with contacts of Mike Florio
or anything else there I mean again
Green Bay fans if you're mad just be mad
at your own team right now they started
this mess and that's the issue here but
I don't think it's gonna be an issue for
this team in 2020 and I'm not so sure if
it will be for 2021 either just because
I think Rogers is still so talented he's
still one of the five best quarterbacks
in the game he still got arguably the
second best arm in the game other than
Patrick mahomes you know there's some
other ones that maybe closed the gap a
little bit but Rodgers isn't gonna be
like during practice like oh my gosh
this Jordan Love guy is so talented I'm
so threatened I don't know what to do
no Aaron Rodgers gonna be like how about
that laser Jordan can you do that no
mentor and hopefully Jordan Love will
take it all to take it all in man I mean
gosh I know I was so happy to be playing
under a Super Bowl winning quarterback
like Brad Johnson let alone what it
would be like to play for Aaron Rodgers
and the things he sees and the tricks he
can give you I mean this is a guy that's
Zen master quarterback one of the
greatest of all time so just digest it
all and try to soak up as much as you
can from that guy what was that sound
again laser beam and look you know you
hit the nail on the head Chris the
Packers made this mess by drafting
Jordan Love if you don't draft a
quarterback in round one if you don't
trade up four spots to draft this guy
it's not an issue it's only an issue
because they have added Aaron Rodgers
successor at a time when he's made it
clear he's sticking around for the next
four seasons and he wants to stay beyond
that well now we got a timeline problem
because Jordan Love has a four year
contract with a fifth year option
Aaron Rodgers wants to play into his 40s
with the Packers well that takes him to
five six or seven seasons out this
Jordan Love pick may end up being a
waste so it's right reconcile it and I'm
sorry Packers fans but your team is the
organization that said let's go ahead
and introduce this uncertainty into the
latter stages of Aaron Rodgers career
with the Packers and I still think that
at some level they've looked at this and
said alright we have a guy we can
develop who could take over for Aaron
Rodgers if he dips we have a guy who can
learn from Aaron Rodgers if Aaron
Rodgers decides to treat him better than
Brett Favre treated Aaron Rodgers and
most importantly to the extent that it
pisses Aaron off and makes him better
than he's been in recent years even
better than what we've seen and has out
with a flourish we wait we'll take it
however it plays out it works out well
for us
no no doubt you're right and you know I
think there's a good chance we're gonna
see Aaron Rodgers buckle down and play
some really awesome football would you
know if you made me look into my crystal
ball right here I would go oh this looks
like New England and the Jimmy Garoppolo
situation all over again
except New England didn't use a
first-round pick and use a fourth round
pick to trade up in the first round you
know here's a case where Green Bay a few
years from now Aaron Rodgers still might
be the quarterback and they're trading
Jordan love away and oh it's for a
second or third round pick and it's
gonna I'm gonna sit here and I'm gonna
be the one goddamn you you guys wasting
her first in the fourth round pick two
to get a second or third round pick
great job I don't know about that and
that's to me where it's extremely dicey
with one of the most talented guys we've
ever seen a guy that's playing at a very
high level and of course we know is not
afraid to kind of say shove it where the
Sun don't shine if he does prove
everybody wrong and let's look at the
context before we take a break of what
happened once Jimmy Garoppolo arrived in
New England 2014 ten years since the
team's last Super Bowl win and it's 10
years since the Packers last Super Bowl
win and 41 to 14 Monday night loss to
the Kansas City Chiefs a reporter dares
to
the question of whether or not there's
consideration being given to benching
Tom Brady for Jimmy Garoppolo and you
know just the dismissive attitude from
Bill Belichick well there was a guy in
the back that didn't take a dismissive
attitude he got upset and what happened
Super Bowl win 2014 almost back in the
Super Bowl 2015 Super Bowl win 2016 in
that game for the ages against the
Falcons almost another Super Bowl win in
2017 Super Bowl win in 2018 I mean that
Garoppolo thing lit a fuse on this Late
Late career bomb that was Tom Brady
elevating himself to the best
quarterback of all time so look I'm not
saying the Packers are gonna win three
of the next five Super Bowls but I can
understand the logic there and now maybe
they've gone a little overboard by
making it a first-round pick Chris but
again good problem to have
if Jordan love ends up getting traded to
the 49ers of someone else before he's
ever really played any meaning for
football for the Packers because if that
gets Aaron Rodgers to an even higher
level than he's otherwise gonna occupy
the Packers have made one of the best
moves that they ever have in their
franchise history yeah I mean watch out
I mean you're you're right I mean it's
this is a special football player yeah
it just hey again it's it's it's really
gonna be unbelievable to watch as we go
into the season here I don't understand
it still but I do think Aaron Rodgers
gonna handle it like a professional and
I think Aaron Rodgers is gonna be out to
prove a lot of people wrong this year
and be on his a game more than ever and
Packers fans like to hear that they
don't like to hear about the possibility
of Aaron Rodgers playing somewhere else
which is very real they do like to hear
about the possibility of Aaron Rodgers
finding another gear another level of
performance and getting back to the
Super Bowl and winning it which is
entirely possible as well
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports